What is the evolutionary reason
for having consciousness?
I think that was Toby who
asked that God only knows.
Um,
that's been a problem that people have
been hammering on for a long time.
I mean,
that's the so called Zombie problem
that David Chalmers is as described,
which is something like,
how do you know that other people aren't
exactly like you except acting in a
completely determined matter
and devoid of consciousnesses?
Um,
I don't know what the evolutionary
reason is for consciousness.
I mean,
I can speculate like what
consciousness seems to be,
at least in part,
is,
uh,
a mechanism of repair.
So a lot of the things that
you do are unconscious.
You know,
like when you're driving,
if you're an expert driver,
you're using your eyes to watch the road
and your eyes are moving your hands and
your arms,
but you're not really thinking
about what you're doing.
You're not attending to it consciously
because you've built circuitry already
specialized circuitry that
handles all those tasks.
Now,
what happens when you're driving?
Let's say that you make a mistake.
Well then what happens is you consciously
attend to the mistake and you attempt
to revise the part of the automatic
structure that produced the error.
So imagine this,
imagine you're playing the piano and
you're playing a very complicated,
uh,
sequence and you stumble over part of it.
So you're zooming along and you stumble
over part of it and then you attend to
that and you'd go back and you slow down
and you move your fingers slowly and
you try to reprogram those
little automatic units that
have handled that part of
it.
You repair them and reprogram them and
you get faster and faster out it as they
automatize and then you go.
So consciousness seems to be something
that watches what you do automatically,
checks for errors and then repairs it.
And so that's its function.
Now you might ask why a repair mechanism
like that would have to be associated
with awareness and answered.
That is,
uh,
not only do I not know,
I don't think anyone knows if I was
speculating and which I've done.
I think consciousness actually plays
an integral role in being itself,
because I'm not convinced that there would
be any being of any recognizable sort
without a conscious observer.
So I think consciousness is
actually like a center point of,
of the cosmos in some sense.
And I think it's because
of ideas like that,
that the,
the grand archetypal idea of the soul
has emerged and I think it's correct.
Um,
so,
but how to precisely integrate
that with evolutionary theory,
um,
apart from the description
that already provided,
I just don't,
I just don't know.